- All right, smiths.
Welcome to our strength test.
The ammo can stab and chop.
But what your blades do to
the cans, I don't really care.
I want to see what the cans
are going to do to your blades.
John, I know you're
ready for this, right?
Rock and roll.
Let's do it.
JON: My heart is going 1,000
miles an hour right now.
The only thing I'm really
worried about is that guard.
I didn't get as solid a
fit up as I wanted to.
That guard is a
little bit sloppy.
[music playing]
Yeah, boy.
China's a beast.
But it's actually a
fairly comfortable beast.
The leather behind
the guard, I mean,
it's still there but
it makes it move a bit.
But there's no cracking.
There's no huge chunks
taken out of it.
Everything's tight.
Nicely done.
Thank you.
All right, Mike.
What's the Marine
Corps got to say?
Do this.
Let's do it.
MIKE: I am very nervous.
Jon just went.
His blade dented that
can up really nice.
My turn.
Let's do this.
[music playing]
Good boy.
All right, Mike.
Some handle things, it's
a very large handle.
That being said, with this big
chunk of brass on the back,
I was able to generate a
lot of force in that stab.
Only problem is, we did
take a bit of your tip off
in the stab.
Except for a few little
chips and a snapped tip,
you still got a good edge there.
Good job.
Thank you.
You can breath, brother.
Breath now.
You breath now.
Jim, I know you're ready.
Always.
JIM: I'm feeling pretty good
about going into testing.
My blade's something
the size that I
would have used in Vietnam.
[music playing]
Well, we've got a
couple issues, Jim.
The big issue is your edge here.
On those three chops, the
can kind of won on that one.
I think your edge got too
thin when you were grinding.
But otherwise, it's all
tight, nothing blew apart.
Nicely done.
- Thank you.
Good job.
Bladesmiths, this
is the sharpness test.
The resupply bundle slice.
Jon, you're up first.
You're ready?
Let's do it.
DOUG: Let's do this.
[music playing]
All right, Jon.
It's a big blade but it's evenly
balanced all the way through.
Overall, it will cut.
Thank you, sir.
That's I wanted to hear.
All right, Mike.
You ready?
Let's make this happen.
DOUG: Let's do this.
[music playing]
Mike, let's talk
about your blade.
First up, I love the balance.
It feels good.
And as you can
see, it cut easily.
It will cut.
Thank you.
DOUG: Good job.
All right, Jim.
Your turn.
You ready?
Let's do it.
DOUG: Let's do this.
During the ammo
can chop I lost
several pieces of the blade.
I'm really hoping at
least I can cut something.
[music playing]
This is not good.
All right, Jim.
Let's talk about your blade.
The handle itself feels good.
Of all the blades,
this is very light.
In the swing, it feels good.
It's got a good
balance to it but you
are missing chips right there
off the metal right there.
It is just not sharp enough
to cut through the cord.
I understand.